Where's this Where's this Asmin Gold tweet at? I read this this
morning and I was like, "Oh my god, this guy gets it." He could
come across JD Vance his mom's corpse and JD Vance could say,
"Well, it's a made in America flesh and Asmin Gold would defend
it." That's how completely debased these subhuman losers are.
Literally, the administration can take any position they want
and there will always be people like this who will find some
way to make an excuse for it. So, let me just finish my point,
please. Holy [__] Um, Hassad has more influence.
And when he talks about this conflict in particular, and he talks
about Jews, he I'm just going to say he's talking about Jewish
people. He's not talking about Israelis. He's not talking about
Zion. He's just talking about Jews as a whole.
Okay, let's check it out. Where's this Where's this Asmin Gold
tweet at? I read this this morning and I was like, "Oh my god,
this guy gets it. This guy gets it." How the did he actually
nail it so perfectly? Okay, first uh apparently this started
off from a clip. Okay, I don't want to. Ah, man. You know what?
We'll have time. We'll have time. Let me start with this. This
is Asmin Gold talking about it today. Okay, why don't we start
with that? Uh, let me see. We can cover We can cover Asmin Gold's
actual reaction and him talking about it and then we'll read
the tweets at the same time. Okay, we'll read the tweets at the
same time. I'm sure that I'm sure he watches the See if I can
find it, too. Where's Destiny? Did you say Destiny? There it
is. And uh yeah, I would assume so. Being harassed. What is this
here? Triggered. Don't let fascist adjacent people who celebrate
arbitrary malicious firing of federal employees. This is uh this
is his response to ask right here. So Destiny is mad. So this
is what's happened with Destiny. And I I don't want to give but
like or talk about it a whole lot, but basically um Destiny has
gone back and forth about this over and over. Did this happen
today? Yes, it happened this morning. Okay.
and he made a joke about like how uh I would defend JD Vance
having sex with like my dead mother or something like that. Just
like a weird comment, unhinged comment, etc. And so like this
is what I said and this is what I think a lot of Destiny's community.
Oh wait, hold on. Did he not watch the clip? We'll watch the
clip then. Hold on. Let's uh let's watch the clip. Destiny takes
major shots at Asmin Gold. He could come across JD Vance his
mom's corpse and Vance could say it was made it's say well it's
a made in America fleshlight and Asminold would defend it. That's
how completely debased these subhuman losers are. Doing it was
to retaliate for tariffs against other countries that weren't
real. Wait, what did as what did Destiny think about Caseyron
talking about Asmin Gold's mom? Can we find that clip? Didn't
Destiny have a whole take about how Caseyron was a completely
subhuman disgusting piece of for talking about Asmin Gold's mom?
Isn't that Did we lose that entirely now? It's like Asmin go.
Oh, Asmin Gold deserved it. Actually, now he's
uh when Destiny like when Destiny confronts somebody and says
they're a disgusting piece of he's like writing down the tech
to use it later. Like when Vasha was like, "Oh, we got to like
these conservatives." He was like, "Oh, let me write that down.
You're a piece of by the way. You're a sarcastic terrorist, but
I'm going to use this later." Going back on those reciprocal
tariffs claiming. Why is talking about Lena off limits, but Asmin's
mom is fine? Because Destiny obviously has no principles. He's
never had principles. He just acts emotionally at all times.
It was to get a better deal. Yeah. Real time. Of course, he's
going back on the tariffs because these people are coming to
the table to negotiate with them. The tariffs were a bargaining
chip to begin with. That was the entire point of the tariffs.
Do you think there'll ever be a world where they I'm trying to
imagine like if they start nullifying people's actual US citizens
if they'll care? No, they wouldn't. Asmin slop would absolutely
100%.
because they would they wouldn't start with Now that's probably
true. Okay, that is probably true that Asmin Gold would find
a way to defend it. Asmin Gold is totally he is like the worst.
Okay, when it comes to political takes, but you have to you have
to do something here. You have to be able to understand why he's
able to tap into like a big audience and stuff, right? And have
some understanding there. But yeah, the he Destiny has none of
that. Like, you know, Joe Blow, right? they're going to start
with someone that became a citizen um from whatever reason. Like
they they always find a way to recode whatever is being stated.
They always find a way to recode it into a way that's acceptable.
He could come across JD Vance his mom's corpse and JD Vance could
say, "Well, it's a made in America flesh and Asmin Gold would
defend it." That's how completely debased these subhuman losers
are. Literally, the administration can take any position they
want and there will always be people like this who will find
some way to make an excuse for it. It's beyond It's depravity.
But I don't Okay, that was a little much. I was just saying like
no matter what h like you saw him competing there for I Do you
think Dan's a little annoyed that they're picking so many fights
at the same time? Like it just feels like I don't know if you
want to fight Asmin Gold and Hassan at the same time. Dan saying
it's too much. Wait, nobody here is saying, "Oh, Asmin Gold has
good political takes." It's just like, do you have to talk about
people his mom's dead corpse or I don't know. I guess the moment
he's like, "They went back on the tariffs." Of course they went
back on the tariffs. Like, yeah, that's cuz it was a negotiating
thing. They brought the tariffs back. Yeah. Because it helps
our manufacturing. Like no matter what happens, they're always
going to Yeah. You know, well, the tariffs were always there
because it's supposed to help manufacturing. It's just uh Trump
is insane. And that the tariffs would never work for anything
because obviously obviously they um they were too much. And nobody
can you can't tariff somebody build a factory immediately. And
and not only that, okay, not only that, but obviously it's going
to take people want stability to build factories. Yeah, there's
a there's a whole bunch of reasons why the tariff policies and
you would just say that. I don't know why I it's just Yeah, it's
like that. But here here's the thing. I agree with how No, it's
not. It's not the same thing. And bring somebody's like dead
mom into it is just weird. And I think he only does that because
he knows that Caseyron's done it. It upset Asmin Gold before,
right? Like that's that's basically all it is there. Anyway,
so as gold is politically, but he actually totally gapes Destiny
like mercilessly here. A lot of people excused deranged outbursts
like this in Destiny's community because they think Destiny is
fighting for a greater good that supersedes any form of accountability
or decency. What they fail to realize is that crashes like this,
his comments towards the firefighter who during the Trump assassination
attempt and the kid with brain cancer who was given an honorary
secret service role actively damage any cause he advocates for.
Yes, he's there's no proof that he's a boon to any cause he advocates
for at all. Oh my god. Asmin Gold actually just nails it entirely.
Destiny delegitimizes leftwing political goals by using them
as a shield while making vile unwarranted personal attacks. Yes.
Oh my god, it's so funny. And Destiny is so like this is Yes,
this is literally the point I've been making constantly, right?
That hey, this guy is not helping you. He's not helping you.
In fact, he is like the perfect foil. Everything that makes you
like Destiny, there there are eight people like you who hate
Destiny, okay? And use him as their reason. So you like Destiny
because he can talk Andrew Tate and a whole bunch of other people
who you find disgusting. But trust me, way more people hate Destiny
and vote based off of him than than you than people exist in
Destiny's community. All right. Um, anyway, what else did he
say? Hopefully, his community can realize it realize this before
he causes further harm to the causes they claim to care so much
about. They won't. It's a cult. His community is a cult and it's
they're incapable of seeing it. And I say that as somebody who's
a part of the cult, obviously, right? I'm not I'm not even talking
these people and saying like they're it's like a blind it's a
blindness, right? That's the issue. It's it's literally just
a blindness. They can't actually see the harm that's being done.
So, they have no way to protect themselves from it or to stop
it from happening. Like, it is an actual blindness. They are
incapable of seeing the harm. And it's it's it's more sad than
anything, right? But yeah, I trust me, we're figuring out little
ways to break people out. Little by little, we break them out.
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Cyberdrifter. So, okay, there's uh there's
Asold's point. I think he's going to read his own tweet. Understand?
No, no, he actually actually did. Listen, to get a better deal.
Yeah, real time. Of course, he's going back on because these
people are coming to the table to negotiate. I watch his content
knowing he's a piece of But hold on, he could be a piece of [__]
It's that he he doesn't care enough about the causes to control
that he's a piece of like like that's why I keep saying if you
guys actually like cared about politics, you would watch Pisco
or Josiah, right? Like Destiny is actively falling behind them
rhetorically, they are way ahead of him rhetorically. They're
way better at arguing the points. They have been. And for as
long as they weren't giving him points, they were as well, right?
They're way better at arguing the points. They're just so much
better at arguing them. And they don't detract from the cause
for their own, you know, impulses. They don't go and do things
for their own impulses, for their own on their own whims to with
the cause at all. They're all about the cause. The cause is above
them. And they are they're are servants to that cause. Destiny
is incapable of that. Destiny is far too much of a narcissist
to be a servant to anything. He doesn't care enough about the
cause to put his unhinged thoughts like in a box and keep them
there. It's just it's there's no part of him that's like that
with them. The tariffs were No, they wouldn't. Asmin slop would
absolutely 100 [__] percent. So because they would
they wouldn't start with um like you know Joe Blow, right? They're
gonna start I've seen them all argue. No, it's it's literally
like Pisco has been better at arguing than Destiny for a long
time. Pisco has basically always been better at arguing than
Destiny. Pisco is a much better debater than Destiny. He's much
more intelligent than Destiny. He's much more driven than Destiny.
He's much better prepared than Destiny. Pisco is basically better
in every single way. Destiny is far more entertaining. Yeah,
but hold on. Just as as long as you know OMFG, he's pro, you're
you're substituting that entertainment for political effectiveness.
You are literally building up somebody who's willing to take
entertainment value and and arrandizing themselves and put it
way above the political project. So, you are actually harming
your political project as long as you're comfortable harming
your political project. I know most DGers just like they cope
and they're like, "No, no, no. I'm uh I'm like doing good by
watching this guy and building him up." But actually, you're
harming the political project for your entertainment. As long
as you're fine with that, it's totally cool. It's I'm fine with
that. As long as you can understand and make peace with that,
it's all good. With someone that became a citizen um from whatever
reason, like they they always find a way to recode whatever is
being stated. They always find a way to recode it into a way
that's acceptable. He could come across JD Vance, his mom's corpse,
and JD Vance could say, "Well, it's a made in America flashlight."
And Asmin Gold would defend it. That's how completely debased
these subhuman losers are. Literally. So, the thing is with Destiny
and saying stuff like this, right? And and I I want to let you
guys know. Uh, no, hooligans, you couldn't have. Um, horniness
actually has very little to do with why Destiny is a bad person.
Um, people say that and they like joke about it. It actually
has very, very, very little to do with him being a bad person.
People think it does. People kind of cope about that and they're
like, "Oh, it's all the horniness. If he could just stop being"
It's not. He's just a really bad person. That's it. He's just
a really bad There's no horniness here, right? He's just a really
bad person. That like I don't really take this very personally.
My mom wouldn't have given a about this. Like I I don't It's
not like I'm offended or upset by this at all. It's just being
an idiot. Rewind and listen to the Asmin Gold response. Oh, sorry,
sorry, sorry. Am I not listening close enough? Whatever is being
stated, they always find a way to recode it into a way that's
acceptable. He could come across. Did I go back further far enough?
Are you watching you back? Sorry, I'm not really paying attention.
I'm mostly arguing with chat and then I'm letting this play in
between. JD Vance his mom's corpse and JD Vance could say, "Well,
it's a made in America flesh and Asmin Gold would defend it."
That's how completely debated. Let's pay close attention to Mr.
Literally. So, the thing is with Destiny and saying stuff like
this, right? And and I uh Jenji, thank you for the 11 month celebration.
Let's go. I want to let you guys know that like I don't really
take this very personally. My mom wouldn't have given a about
this. Like I I I don't It's not like I'm offended or upset by
this. Um Hooligans, it it doesn't matter. It's not about like
even what he uh it's not really about what he says. It's that
he is a rallying cry for the people against him and he is constantly
like a totally unhinged degenerate rallying cry. Like literally
he is he is as powerful as anybody in media at getting the other
side rallied against you. Like as much as you might hate Ben
Shapiro, people hate Destiny more. As much as you might hate
Asmin Gold, people hate Destiny more. And you I people in DGG
can't see it. They don't see that he's like totally detestable
and he drives voter participation on the other side so much more
than any help he could possibly give. Is this even true? Oh yeah.
Yeah. You don't think there are tons of conservatives who are
like, "Yeah, this guy this guy forever is Destiny that big."
He literally argued with every major conserv conservative influencer
like two years ago. Yes. At all. He's just being an idiot. Most
people don't even You're totally wrong. OMFG. He's pro. But the
point is that Destiny and I think this is what a lot of his community
does is that they um they justify anything bad that Destiny does
and any like whether it's the test allegations, the lawsuit for
revenge, weird tweets about like people like I don't even want
to get into the details with that. Uh you know, him saying that
stuff about the guy that got shot at the Trump assassination.
Oh, he doesn't even maybe Asminold also doesn't know about the
uh the persistent doxing threats over time. Hey, stop talking
about me or I'm going to dox people and then him posting the
docs himself. Even Asminold doesn't know about that. It turns
out crazy rally him saying bad stuff about the kid that got put
up there to make an honorary secret service member stuff like
this, etc. I think that a lot of his community tries to defend
and they say it's okay that destiny does this because he's actively
working and advocating for a worldview that we think is good.
So it's basically like the ends justify the means. And the problem
with him doing that is that I think when an average person hears
this and they see him saying this, it actively damages any cause
that he's trying to promote. And you can even see him, he's not
really um uh like would defend Trump executing US citizens for
arbitrary reasons if he started doing it. Um and so this is just
basically Destiny creates a false narrative. He creates a hypothetical
situation that didn't happen, hasn't happened, and probably won't
happen. Oh. Ah, it's so good that Asmin Gold points this out.
Yes. Like Asmin Gold's like, "Here's how your behavior affects
the people around you, Destiny." And and Destiny's like, "Well,
Asmin Gold would do this crazy thing. I'm going to make up a
situation where Asmin Gold would do this crazy thing." Guys,
look at this crazy thing I just said Asmin Gold would do. It's
like, okay, could you point to what he has done? What he has
done is already bad enough with regards to politics, right? How
he consistently does minimize what the Trump administration is
doing from a like really bad like he obviously is a total sickopant
for the Trump administration. It's already bad enough. you don't
have to make up new things in order to justify uh acting insane,
right? He's just made up this problem. He's basically made up
a situation that justifies his own behavior. And also, you can
see that in all of his defense of what I said about him, in no
point in time is he saying that I'm wrong. That's Yes. Yes. Where's
the defense of what of of like his behavior and what he does?
Where's the defense? Where's any engagement at all with what
Asmin Gold actually said? Where is it? Where's the engagement?
He just makes up some crazy [__] about Asmin Gold.
He just says some crazy about him, right? Okay. Make up. Hold
on. He does celebrate He probably does celebrate the malicious
firing of of federal employees. I'm talking about the um the
thing he he he makes up the hypothetical here, but like there's
already all these things he's done. Why don't you point out how
Asmin Gold is harmful to society instead of just like making
up hypotheticals? I don't know. and then engage maybe a little
bit with what he said. He can't defend what I'm saying, he knows
for a fact what I'm saying is true. And the sooner his audience,
but this is like a big thing for Destiny right now, right? Destiny
and probably to some extent Dan know that they can't defend any
of his behavior and so we'll be consistently trying to get people
rallied to fight against other bad people. Right? That's all
Destiny can do. Destiny doesn't have a defense for his conduct.
And so he's going to consistently point his community at other
people and say, "Look how bad these people are. Look how bad
these people are. Look how bad that guy is. Look how bad Asmin
Gold is. Look how bad Hassan is. Look how bad JTO is. Look how
bad these guys are." Right? It's never going to be, "Oh, like
here's me actually sitting down and defending my conduct and
saying this is why it's untrue." Like even looking at the Pixie
lawsuit, you know what his defense is in the Pixie lawsuit, right?
It's yes, I did it, but it was before it could have possibly
been charged against me. That's his only defense. He is dead
to rights guilty on all of the actual like elements of the charge.
It is just that the law went into effect I think uh like six
months after about 6 months after he did the he actually in broke
it. So it it wasn't in effect. I did all of the elements. Yes.
But it was wasn't in effect yet. That's his defense for the Pixie
lawsuit right now for the civil suit. That's the only defense
he has. Right. It's not actually defending his his conduct at
all. And he will consistently go, "Oh, look. Pixie lied. Pixie
Pixie's lawyers up the date. They lied. Look how look how she's
lying about everything. No, it's like a date that's wrong and
you already admitted you did it and we all know you're guilty.
Like it's there's no defense of the conduct. There's no actual
looking at his morale his his moral conduct and saying, "Oh,
this was probably up." Or, "Oh, this would be bad if it were
true." There's no nothing like that, right? It's just pointing
people at other targets so that he can't be questioned
realizes it and they start holding him accountable for acting
this way, the sooner that he can make more tangible change and
do things that are meaningful. Because right now, Destiny's burned
so many bridges with so many people. You don't need to act like
this. You don't want to act like this. People don't like you
when you act like this. When clips like this hit the mainstream
audience, people [__] on you. And people [__]
on me for saying this, too. But the difference is that I said
that it was a joke and you're being serious. That's the difference.
And also, I'm not going out and doing this while you're still
advocating for shooting Donald Trump. And so, the problem is,
and that's why you had to delete the tweet, by the way. You should
be lucky that you're not banned. But Destiny is right. There
are far worse people than him that he will fight. No, he is a
far far worse person than Asmin Gold or Hassan on like a personal
level. You can say, "Oh, these guys make a lot of money like
by farming bad causes or something, but on a in terms of like
the people they know, they take care of the people they know.
They are relatively like good people, the people they know most
of the time. Unless you just want to say Trump is worse. But
then all then basically you're succumbing to an argument where
as long as there's a worse person in the world than the second
worst person, you can't criticize the second worst person or
dislike them. Oh well, there's always a worse person. Like what
is this argument? Can we not can we not actually just criticize
all the bad people at once? Why would you why would you just
why would you allow somebody to be a terrible person? Why would
you allow them to lead your movement and sabotage your movement
consistently just because they criticize somebody from another
movement who sucks? Hassanabi causes more harm in the world than
Destiny based on what? Where's the harm we can attribute to Hassan?
Just show me. Show me the harm we can attribute to Hassan. Actually,
demonstrate the harm we can attribute to Hassan. Hassan is and
18year-olds to 24 year olds watch him. the lowest voting the
lowest prevalence voter bracket watches Assad and they're but
they've always been that that voter group has always been and
that voter group is trending conservative really like you you're
you're going out and you're advocating for the assassination
of political people and you're you're going and chirping out
about this complaining about what other people are saying you
should be glad you're not banned so the fact is and he's going
to eventually he will preaching ideas that will make the next
generation disillusioned with the system. Every every college
age girl is a communist. What? That's always been true. That
was true in like the 80s, in the '9s, in the 2000s, in the 2010s
before Hassan was ever involved with anything. Are we How are
we this dumb that we think Hassan is like actually making all
these college like he is just a communist they follow? He's not
teaching them to be communists. I don't know. People are like
really dumb. Trump is bad. Okay, Trump. I will never doubt the
the badness of Hassan is like actually far less harmful in the
world than I think a lot of people give him credit for. Hop off
because I think that Destiny has become increasingly more unhinched.
And also before I go into this anymore, uh the worst thing Hassan
did was the was the terrorist uh apologia. That's like the worst
thing I've seen Hassan do is the terrorist apology, right? The
oh, I'm going to bring this guy on. I'm going to kind of like
soften the reputation of Ansarah. I'm going to go and cheer while
they kidnap these civilians. That's the bad, right? That's like
the worst. But I can look at that and just evaluate it and say,
"Oh, I'm very critical of that." Yes, that's very easy for me
to do. No, of course I would not support Trump assassinating
and people for random reasons like random arbitrary reasons.
Like why would I You think preaching ideas doesn't have real
world effects? It does have real world effects, but Hassan is
not advocating. But like, and I think people the closest Hassan's
come to advocating violence is the uh the Tom Cotton tweet. That's
the closest he's come I've seen like to him like really advocating
violence hardcore against somebody, right? Destiny just straight
up says like these people should been shot. These people should
be I don't I feel no problem. I have no problem with these people
getting right. I think the person pushing stochastic terrorism
is destiny by far way over all these other people pushing racist
propaganda, racism against white and Polish people, etc. Uh yeah,
I think that that is something he does that's negative. I just
don't think I think that's broadly him, you know, to the culture
in a lot of ways. But hey, I I'm just willing to say that I just
don't think he's that effective. I don't think he's that effective.
I think most people grow out of I think he happens to be the
hot guy who get who takes these bad ideas and gives them like
a home. I don't think he's like a thought leader and I don't
think most people think of him as like a thought leader in any
way. Hassan is pushing hateful re rhetoric. He makes hating Jews
acceptable. No, he doesn't. No, he doesn't. How many times does
he have to say that like hatred of Jews and anti-semitism is
wrong for you to disagree? For you to not support that. He's
at most He's at most dog whistling. He doesn't make hating Jews
acceptable. That's crazy. I I didn't even There were tons of
things I didn't support Trump with. I didn't support him with
Row versus Wade. I didn't support him with uh let's see what
else. I'm trying to think about some of the other examples of
things that have been with Ukraine. I didn't support him with
like how he's approached healthc care. There's been tons of things
that I haven't supported him with with the tariffs. Yeah, I think
the the tariff stuff when we watched was a little better, but
then here's a clip of Asmin Gold sort of softening on the terror
on the tariff. I told I told Queen this. We were like watching
and Asmin Gold was kind of like, "Oh, well this seems pretty
bad." And I was like, "Dude, he'll forget it next week and he'll
be defending this 100%." And this appears to be a clip of him
saying, "Oh, well, the tariffs were reversed because of this,
so unlucky settler babies." I mean, that's him. Listen, when
he says that, he's like, "Oh, that exists." He's saying a fact
that's insane to say at the moment, in the moment. Right. But
do you think Hassan believes that Israeli babies deserve to die?
Do you think that Do you think that in your heart of hearts,
you think Hassan thinks Israeli babies deserve to die for being
there? If you if you say yes to that, I think you're insane.
I think you're completely insane. I think I think that's a good
sign that you're probably unhinged. Tariffs went way overdue.
I think January 6 was awful. Uh the exemptions of letting the
people out like Yeah. So like this isn't even it's a completely
madeup reality that Destiny has created for his audience in order
to justify being a uh a weirdo, right? Just being a weirdo. And
Hamas [__] defended Second Thought for saying that.
He defended he did the same thing. He actually did the Kelly
argument which is like true but it's to say it's like yeah there
are settler babies that is a thing that exists right there are
settler babies you could say that it's like a level one thought
that you're like oh on a technical on a technical level without
going to level two right but as soon as you go to level two and
you're saying well you know that kind of leads to them justifying
those people right you go well obviously I don't want that right
yes well Maximus it's just in his head he's like yeah there are
settler babies technically he's like trying to defend his friend
and then as soon as You take him to the level two thought of
well people will take the fact that they're settler babies and
they will use that to justify violence against those kids against
those those infants and he'll go oh well obviously I don't want
that right do you see Hassan as a salesman for these kinds of
things I see Hassan as like a propheteer for a culture that exists
yes I don't I don't I don't personally see him as a thought leader
in any way shape or form but I guess you guys do maybe I I don't
know why he does this and I I'm going to as somebody who's watched
Destiny for like eight years and like on and off. I'm not a big
DGER or anything like that, but I've watched him on and off.
I really think that ever since I think that ever since
2023, he's really begun to get way more unhinged, and he's become
much more costic. He's become much more personal, much more vicious.
And I think Destiny is the perfect example of the old quote,
"If you gaze into the abyss long enough, the abyss will gaze
back into you." Wow, that's so poignant from Asmin Gold. Isn't
Asmin Gold smart, guys? He just threw out some Nichi. Okay, Asmin
Gold's a big Nichi reader. Let's go. I think that he spent so
long fighting against what he considers to be these evil people
that are conservatives or whatever that he has become one of
them. He's doing the same things that they do. Jericho, thanks
for the 10 subs. I appreciate it. And I think he's doing the
same things that they do. He's acting the same way. And the only
way that he can justify his bad behavior. It's like again, uh
I guess you can use like the metaphor of like a uh a house of
cards where like a house of cards can't stand with one individual
card. But the the thing is here's the thing. Destiny is not justifi.
He basically goes and he takes um how could I explain it? I can
kind of think of it visually, but I don't want to pull out the
Photoshop thing until I can think of it for sure. Basically,
what Destiny does is he he webs together a whole bunch of people,
right? and he takes the worst people from that possible bracket
and then he will take everybody who's possibly on like the side
or in the remote bubble of those bad people that if you could
do any connection from the really bad people, okay, like uh let's
say like a Fuentes type or anybody adjacent to that or Trump
himself, if you could web through like eight degrees of connection
to Asmin Gold, he will treat Asmin Gold like he is Trump himself,
right? He will have as little regard for Asminold's safety, Asmin
Gold's happiness or well-being. As the things Asminold holds
sacred like his his mom or his family or anything, he'll he'll
treat him as if it's Trump, right? I will do anything to [__]
you up right now. That's what he does. But it's like it's this
webbing along, right, between all the people. You take like the
absolute worst people that you can. So he's done this to me as
well, right? He'll say like, "Oh, I'm treating Jtock or Queman
or whoever like they like consort directly with Kiwi Farms or
something, right?" And then he can do whatever whatever those
Kiwi Farms people have done, he can do to me or Quimman or Kelly
or whoever the right he thinks that's a legitimate thing to do.
And when you when you combine that with like his his penchant
for escalating massively over what other people do, right? It
just leads to these insane desperate moments where he's like
talking about JD Vance, Asmin Gold's dead mom when Asmin Gold
like realistically he like has some decency there and he can
just sit back and point out that this guy looks insane and Destiny
gets ratioed massively. Destiny gets like blown the out. So like
40,000 live viewers measures to what 40% of all anti-semitic
incidents. I'm not exactly sure this works. Did Hassan ever say
the words Jews or evil? No. Hassan broadly like talks. So it's
one of those things where he says he doesn't like anti-semitism.
He preaches against anti-semitism but he will do ideas he will
he will push ideas that from groups that are anti-semitic that
are broadly anti-semitic and then he will use the justification
well these are the only groups who fight for the people who are
being persecuted in the region and now that I disagree with that
argument but it is an argument and people think that it's like
um like it's totally invalid it's not totally invalid I just
think it's bad it it's just a bad thing to do right but I don't
think it's like him he's not like Nick Fentes it's not even close
it has to be pushed pushed up against something else, right?
And that he doesn't need to say directly Jews are evil. He could
spew anti-semitic views and ideals and never be push back on
his audience for being anti-semitic. What anti-semitic views
or ideals has he pushed? Which which ones has he pushed? Hold
on, King Gedra. Go ahead. Tell me what anti-semitic ideals Hassan
has pushed. I just I hope you have something here. Actually,
you could hop in voice if you want. If you want to hop in voice
right now, you could do it. I've got a pretty good idea of the
things he's done, right? Are we are we totally are we totally
throwing away the idea that like Hassan has some argument? You
understand that Hassan has some argument, right? I don't think
he's correct. I think his arguments are but they're not like
they're not fake. They're not made up. They have some like basis
in reality, right? Like Israel is objectively like totally Gaza
up. the Palestinian people are totally from the river to the
sea, claiming that the state of Israel wants to genocide Palestinians.
Uh, broadly, Benjamin Netanyahu wants to to basically kick everybody
out of Gaza in the West Bank. He's said as much multiple times
off the record, like in in private meetings and stuff, right?
Depending on if you equate an ethnic cleansing and a genocide,
those are pretty close. Like, sorry, he he's come pretty close.
And a lot of people do equate essentially like an ethnic cleansing
and a genocide. I don't. But I don't think it's like I don't
think it's right to say that people who do equate those things
are I don't think it's right to say they're anti-Semitic. That's
crazy. Do you think Israel I Well, I just answered your question.
I don't think that people who think that Israel wants to genocide
Palestinians are anti-semitic. What about the pig dog comments?
That's a comment he makes. It's talking about cops. It's talking
about fascists. That's literally anti-fascist. I've pointed that
out a thousand times. I pointed that out with Dan when he was
here that the pig dog thing is to bring up. It's completely It's
just propaganda. You guys are being propagandized by people too.
It's very sad of like a uh a house of cards where like a house
of cards can't stand with one individual card. I see you in Twitch
watching it back. I see you. It has to be pushed up against something
else, right? And that's the only way that this type of behavior.
Bengavir said worse in the sunlight. Yeah, but I don't hold the
the Israeli government responsible for Bengavir's statements.
That would be crazy. can exist is in the context of him justifying
it by creating straw men of people who he disagrees with justifying
things that he thinks are similar. And I think that I need to
back up a little bit for arguing a lotual card. It has to be
pushed up against something else, right? And that's the only
way that this type of behavior can exist is in the context of
him justifying it by creating straw men of people who he disagrees
with justifying things that he thinks are similar. Um I don't
even think it has to be. He happened to do a straw man here of
Asmin Gold. Although I don't think it's like that crazy. The
idea that Asmin Gold would excuse things I think is mostly rude
in reality. I just think going to the extreme level he did it
as gold like a foot to stand on here, right? You could say, "Hey
Asmin Gold, like here's an example. Asmin Gold, you while while
Trump was announcing the tariffs or while those global tariffs
were happening and then he put the exemptions out, you were like,
"Oh, I don't know what he did. He seems to have given China all
the cards and now here he is like a a few days later and he's
like defending Trump again, right?" So, there is some reality
there. So, I'm not going to say that there is no reality there
that Asmin Gold mostly like will defend the Trump administration
broadly on whatever they say. I think that's mostly true. That's
that's my opinion of him from watching quite a bit of his content
is it seems like he'll he'll go and he'll like be against them
and then he'll I I I assume he has like private conversations
with people in his Discord, people he talks to personally and
they're like, "Oh, here's like what you should say about this."
And then he kind of resets after a while, right? Um yeah, so
I I think you can do that, right? But when Desi goes totally
unhinged on him, talks about like JD Vance his dead mom, it's
like, okay, well yeah, nobody wants to be around that. Nobody
wants to be associated and and he's also not he's not defended
his own behavior. I think Asen Gold hit on something very poignant
though that I've been saying. Okay, now Asmin Gold maybe he's
a viewer of the stream sometimes. Who knows? But he is correct
that Destiny does rely on being in opposition to people to get
away with his insane statements, right? He needs to build up
a villain for his audience that he's going to slay so he can
say whatever insane unhinged thing he wants to say, right? And
you can justify it. And so that's that's this process, this cycle
that happens over and over and over again with Destiny's community
is they will build up a villain, somebody who's evil, somebody
who can you can do anything against, right? So that he can be
unhinged and insane and go wherever he wants and do whatever
the he wants and just broadly have no impulse control whatsoever,
right? That's how he justifies this, right? But it's it's like
a cycle that happens over and over again. And it's why when when
this first kicked off, I was very very very clear that I like
I was like, "Oh, you should probably try to rethink almost everything
you've learned from that community about specific people because
they've very much tried to demonize people in your head. So,
you should really like try to rethink and try to like reset on
most people because I I think it's pretty dangerous to just go
with like Destiny's totally one-sided, you know, versions of
people. I think there's a there's a there's some depth to the
people there and then there are people that there isn't really
depth with. Okay, there are other people that are like probably
just bad, but I think I think the reset was important or I I
felt like it was important for me. Like I reset on Assan and
I can sit here and be like, "Yeah, I can criticize specific behaviors
of Assan. It's no problem. It's really easy, but I don't have
to act like he is the worst human being on Earth." And I think
that ultimately Destiny, there are a lot of things that Destiny
does and says that I agree with. And again, like I'm trying not
to I guess I am making this kind of personal. That's actually
not true. I am kind of making this personal, but I hope he can
see that the the way that he's made these things personal. I
think that they actively work against his goals and he is actively
making things. I think more people see what Destiny says and
they see these clips and they go farther away from leftwing ideology
than towards it.
ultimately when you're advocating for something and your behavior
is causing people and again like I don't know whether this is
true but I think it is. I think that when you're joking around
about you know somebody's dead mom making fun of cancer kids.
These are things that average people don't like. And also by
the way average people didn't like that I said
thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Oh my god. Uh let's see here. He's he's just right
about this, right? Like normies don't want to watch this guy.
Normies don't like this. Normies really don't like it. And it
gives Asmin Gold all the ammunition he needs to just go look
how insane this guy is. He's like totally and it's like dude,
I can completely disagree with Asmin Gold's politics and go why
did this have to happen? Why does this guy have to be like a
complete completely like self-interested loser? Why can't he
why can't he put his political movement about above himself in
any way? Why does he always have to make it like Asmin Gold said
personal? Why does he have to make it personal? Why does he have
to go after and attack these people and try to like Yeah. use
use all of their personal against them? Like again, I remember
when the Caseyron thing came out and Casey Tron used Asold's
mom against him, Destiny was like, "Oh, that's reallyed up. Oh,
that's not cool." And now he's like, "Well, actually, you're
you're like a political shill, so now I can do that, too." Okay.
He's a recruitment tool for the right. I saw that four years
ago. I think broadly that's true. Never have time to chat, but
wanted to say a few things while listening in the background.
Destiny is not entertaining. He is for a fringe community, but
for 95% of people that vote, he is repulsive. Also, he's completely
ineffective. Instead of attacking Asmin, he could build a bridge
and get him out of MAGA brain rot, which arguably could be way
more effective than any canvasing he's done so far, considering
the audience numbers of Asmin Gold. Yeah. No, I think that's
pretty much true, Dachi. And that's the argument he was making
in 2022, 2021, 2022 when I started watching him and decided I
really like the project. Right. By the time I left, I'd like
totally disengaged from Destiny politically because I was just
like, not unlike Erodite. I was like, "This is like the politics
you're engaging with, the things you're trying to do politically,
they're stupid. It's never going to work." Destiny can't seem
to perceive. He's like bought into his own cult now where what
what the world is actually like is Destiny has his little circus
with the with the cult members in there, right? And basically
anybody who can see that circus for more than 30 seconds goes,
"Oh, like that's disgusting. I can't believe people do that."
And they laugh. They point and laugh, right? Bro, to DJs, most
people are pointing and laughing. I had to step out of the circus
to realize most people are pointing and laughing, right? And
Asmin Gold's pointing that out to him, too. Hey, we're all laughing
at you. We all think you're losers. We're all laughing at you.
Everybody else, most of the world, we're all laughing at you,
right? But the cult can't see it. They think, "Oh, this is super
important." All the people Destiny will pull in one person who's
laughing at him, right? Pull them into the circus tent. and then
that person will get mobbed by the cult and they'll go, "Oh,
look how evil this person is." He had so much outreach to the
in the conservatives here before. Yeah. He had the ability to
change hearts and minds. But he didn't want that. He just wants
to, you know, be his zero impulse control self, you know, flailing
around like a child. Just a child having a temper tantrum at
all times. Can't put the movement above himself. Doesn't care
about any of that. Again, just stop watching him. Go watch Pisco.
Go watch Josiah. Go watch somebody who's who's actually got the
facts on the side on their side and who cares about the movement.
Go watch anyone else. But most people can't do it. Most people
are again, they're in the circus tent. They think he's like effective.
They think he's good. Uh last time he's effective is like 2023
at best. This either I'm also an and I'm a victim of this myself.
I'm also a one of the reasons why I always kind of like Destiny
is because I could see some qualities of myself in Destiny. So,
it's not like I'm somehow better than this in a lot of cases,
but I recognize when I do that and I know that it's a bad thing.
And the difference is that I can look at what I'm doing and say,
"Hey, that was over the line. I shouldn't have said that. I'm
being an asshole." He can't. He's so entrenched in this mindset
that conservatism is these terrible, horrible people. And he's
convinced himself of this for better or for worse, whether he's
right or not, he's convinced himself of this. so certainly that
he has now justified the exact same behavior that he's fighting
against. That's what justifi I guess like by his own worldview,
right? By engaging in this like he's he's the person who's like,
"Oh, whatever somebody does to me, I can do to them." Um even
even like once I web, you know, eight links together to try to
connect these people, I can do whatever whatever the worst person
in any, you know, group of eight people has done, I can do to
all of them, right? That's like how he acts. And then I I don't
know. Is he going to be upset when when this stuff starts coming
back? You think there's any truth to the idea that during the
effective time that those conversations were so surface level
that he didn't get into substantive substantive disagreements
and it ended up not being productive? Yes. But not because it
couldn't be productive and not because he it was because apparently
he just didn't argue his own principles or ideas and he just
never spent time. It was just something he had to learn, right?
was how to was how to cut in with his own ideas and refuse to
like agree to disagree or just say whatever. Let's let's like
no no no we have to once you've said something incorrect I have
to correct it and we have to go to the facts on it right and
you have to be polite and patient about going to the facts on
it but what he would do is he would just kind of like let things
go and then he would complain about it after but there was no
thing that says to be polite you have to agree with the other
person you don't you can you can disagree right and you can continue
to say yeah I just I don't see it that way yeah I don't see it
that way yeah I don't see it that way but I I guess he again
it's like no impulse control right no ability to like build things
slowly over time. So he he couldn't have like this slow conversation
that's like, "No, I still don't I still don't agree. We can't
just disagree. No, we're not having a civil conversation. You
haven't listened to anything I've said." But knowing how to do
that while remaining polite is apparently very difficult what
he's doing. And I think it hurts the causes. It hurts himself.
It makes his audience look bad. It radicalizes people for no
reason. And I think it's counterproductive. his only defense
of what I said about him is, "Yeah, but you're doing it, too."
And then also an an imaginary scenario that didn't happen. If
the only way that you can defend your actions is by saying they're
doing it, too, maybe you should ask yourself why that is. Wow.
That's actually is that maybe Asmin go, you know, every once
in a while he does make an okay point. It's kindergarten logic.
Yeah, that's it. I give it things that you said, but it's not
shown in clips either. That's okay. I don't have a problem with
him arguing about things that I said. That's totally okay. I
When when would I complain about that? Exactly. Oh my god. Again,
this is what I said. Hey, if you want to take things that are
being said and just disagree with them like factually, you want
to say, "Oh, he's lying here." I have no problem with that. You
can do that all day. That's totally cool. When you make up insane,
when you say insane, you maliciously lie or you maliciously like
make pe make up about people, then obviously those people are
going to dislike you. I don't know what what I and then you like
have the thinnest of justifications for it too. Although with
Asminold, I think this comment with Asminold, like the whole
thing about Asold's mom, Destiny has about a thousand times more
justification to do that than go after me or uh Hassan. Sorry,
me or Quimman, not Hassan. I don't. And also like I view this
as constructive criticism. I I I do because I view what he's
doing is as destructive. This is destructive. Nor off topic.
Yeah. who only approaches things in bad faith. Uh the higher
and higher he held up, it would be in impossible to maintain
ethical standards. Oh, that's the Jordan Peterson thing, etc.
And so when he he would never go as hard, well, if he did it
to Hassan, he would get like deplatformed unironically. That's
why he won't ever do it to Han. Wait, take a stand for once in
your life, bro. Stop glazing this dude. I don't see this is one
thing that a lot of you guys don't uh Cyberdrifter, thank you
for the 20.
Holy holy moly. 25 gifted.
What? That is a Jesus Christ. Cyberdrifter, thank you very much.
Oh my god. So generous. That's 30 gifted. That is $150. That
is 3345.
Uh that's like almost the whole stream right there. Again, already
our donators are so so generous. Oh my god. Thank you so much,
Cyberdrifter. I love you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Um I was I was actually addressing a point and now I lost it.
Let me go back up to where it was. It was which one? Uh I can't
remember which point. [__] I lost it cuz you that
25 gifted just reset my brain. Let me roll back on as gold. Oh,
somebody was calling him a glazer. Dude. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
don't see this is one thing that a lot of you guys don't understand
about me is that I don't care about other people in just a very
general sense. And that means I don't care when someone's rude
to me. And I don't really care when somebody's nice to me that
much either. It just doesn't affect me very much. I care about
what I care about. I care about myself. I care about doing what
I want to do. And I care about working in an act in in a way
that is beneficial to myself. So when somebody says something
that's incredibly offensive to me and it would make you really
mad, it probably just rolls right off my back like nothing. I
don't really care about this. It doesn't matter to me. It doesn't
hurt my feelings. I don't even think about it 5 minutes later.
So that that's it. I don't what a Asmin Gold is the bigger guy.
Also, I got to go to the bathroom real quick and then we're going
to get on to the H3 stuff. Give me two seconds. We'll we'll finish
up the Asmin Gold segment and then I'm going to get on to H3
and we're going to continue on with the knight. I don't think
that like really getting down and fighting with what I think
Destiny is, which is a porcupine is not beneficial for me. It's
not beneficial for him. Everybody loses. So, why do I want to
get down in the weeds and start arguing and fighting with somebody
who's going to start fighting and getting personal with everything?
It's not beneficial for me. It's not really a winning strategy.
Even if I come out on top, I'm still going to have a bunch of
barbs in me. Why do I want to do that? So, the point is that
I hope his community realizes that all the way that he's been
acting with this is tremendously counterproductive. This is what
I I wrote. A lot of people excuse deranged outbursts like this
in Destiny's community because they think Destiny is fighting
for a greater good that supersedes any form of accountability
or decency. And you see comments like this like for example with
this lawsuit etc uh that he's involved in. You see people and
by the way I've never commented on whether it's true or not.
I didn't even read his statements about it. It's a legal matter.
It's not my it it's not my purview to do this. But the fact is
that um a lot of people have even uh preemptively justified it
by saying if this is what we need to deal with to fight against
fascism then it's okay. No, you don't have to deal with this.
You don't have to have idols that are
manipulators, pests, psychotic
um you know like emotional like just like weirdos. Like you you
don't need this person does not need to be your avatar. And I
I think that Destiny was not always like this. I remember like
I would be on the train wrecks podcast with Destiny ever. Oh
my god. How How is he How is he him so hard? Oh my god. Also,
Asminol has definitely been watching like my stream, right? He's
definitely been watching my stream. He's 100% been watching like
Dude, he's actually These are the exact things I say. These are
the exact things I say all the time. It's so good. It's so good
watching. Oh my god, you win. Uh Myra, thank you for the five
gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Guys, I shut
the timer off. We'll just go as long as we need to today. I'll
try to get to eight hours. Timer doesn't even need to be on.
We're so good. Hey. Hey. How's it going? What's up? Cool. We're
We're about to finish this up. No, I'm just I I've Oh, you're
so annoying. Like I'm trying not to yell at you. That's why I
didn't come on for this segment. But like I think your act Yes.
No, but you know I don't think you understand. Like I think I
do understand. I was here for a whole bunch of the I was here
for a whole bunch of There's a whole bunch of arguments that
happened. I was here for them. I was here for them. I can still
criticize the behavior,
bro. Okay. On the grand scheme of things,
Destiny and Han are still two big pieces of [__]
Okay.
There's no question about it. Very brave. And yeah. Wow. So brave.
And I hope I hope Raiden doesn't hear this. Okay. He's gonna
mug me for a while on the Hassan has more influence than Destiny.
That's why when I say that Hassan is a propagandist and he does
push
ideologies and he does dog whistle, he doesn't want to have What's
the anti-semitic ideology he pushes? What's the anti-semitic
ideology pushes? Let me go to my little that I wrote. Oh, you
you can't just tell me can't just tell me what anti-semitic ideology.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Are you upset at me because I tried to
research before coming in here? You don't want me to just say
out of my ass? Is I'm kind of annoyed that you would have researched
and you can't speak off the cuff when I'm speaking off the cuff.
Well, okay. Look, it's fine. Okay. So because of what Hassan
says about Israelis, I hate people when they say Zionists because
they really mean Jews. Okay. All right. Let's just say Jews.
It's okay. Like just I would rather you just say it that way.
But it's people like Hassan. Wait, wait, wait, wait. You hold
on. Hold on. I need you. I need you. Okay. This is the only way
I can argue with people online who discuss Israel Palestine politically.
Okay. Does Zionism map on to Jew or not? You're I'm going to
hold you to this. Either Zionism, Zionist, Zionism means Jewish
or it doesn't. You have to pick one. You can't dance around and
do it on both sides whenever it's convenient. Okay. So, you're
arguing that Zionist means Jew. Yes. So, now if I refer to like
Zionists, we'll never we'll never ever get to the point where
it's like actually there are a lot of Zionists who aren't Jews,
right? We'll never have to do this. Well, yes, because there
are more than just Jewish people that live in the state of Israel.
Yes. Okay. So, which one which one is it? Okay. But the problem
I'm trying to say is that Okay, are you gonna interrupt me again?
King Gedra, I'll just tell you. King Gedra is saying when Hassan
says it, yes, but Hassan explicitly says no, I don't mean that.
Here's what I mean. So Hassan presents his definition, why do
you reject his definition would be my question for King Gedra?
Oh, you see what he he is lying. So you're just going to say
he's lying and not engage at all. Okay. I mean, oh, how Okay,
if you don't want to engage at all, how do you not see this?
How do you not see this? That's why I'm saying I would rather
Hassan just be honest and say Jew. Okay? Because think about
it this way. When he says Zionist, he's still on Twitch, right?
He's still trying to do this like progressive larist like loop
thing. Like he has to be politically correct to some extent by
saying Zionist. He like he's trying to like get around from just
being anti-semitic in general. Like I think you think anti-semitic
you don't think the way easier explanation for this is that he
believes in the oppressor oppressed dynamic and that it manifests
in something that works against Jews because Jews happen to have
the the power in the Israel Palestine conflict. I think that
explains it way better and it's like super easy and maps onto
so many leftists that I can't even name them all. You can still
have that opinion about the oppressor oppressors without getting
racist. So I'm just asking you where he got racist against Jews.
By the way, if you're going to argue he's racist against whites,
I'd be like totally on your side. But where do you get racist
against Jews? Are you going to pull out the uh like his his beef
with like like ultraorththodox Jews who want to do actually beef?
I'm not pulling up any beef he's had with other people. Oh, I
was going to say his comments on Orthodox Jews that he calls
So, let me just finish my point, please. Holy [__]
Um, Hassan has more influence. And when he talks about this conflict
in particular, and he talks about Jews, he I'm just going to
say he's talking about Jewish people. He's not talking about
Israelis. He's not talking about Zionists. He's just talking
about Jews as a whole. Okay? That same thought process and that
same ideology is going towards these encampments that are going
on at the universities. I'll use Colombia and UCLA as a perfect
example. These people, these groups, I don't care if you defend
Palestine, right? But there is a correct way of going about it.
Like
basically is the thought leader for these groups. Oh my I'm not
saying but it's the same it's the same brain rot. Okay. I I mean
you're going to have to explain. I I'm just going to ask for
like examples and we'll have to explain this instead of just
webbing them together. Remember what I said if he'd let me like
say my point that would be the example and he just keeps interrupting
me. Is this guy okay? I'm looking for clarifications but okay.
I'm sorry for too many clarifications. Kelly Gene, I think I
know it really difficult to make your point if I keep asking
for clarifications. So, I should let you just talk. Okay. So,
in specific examples of UCLA and Colombia, you have these groups
of people who are talking Hamas propaganda with but the issue
is is that these people who are genuinely pro Palestine, right?
Because the correct take is wanting a two-state solution. Okay?
We don't want people being oppressed. I'm I'm sorry. The correct
take isn't necessarily wanting a two-state solution. It's what
I want, but I Why would you say it's the correct take? Because
it's the most humane thing to want. You either want the entire
destruction of these
animals. Okay, I'm sorry. That was me being Jewish. I'm sorry.
I hate
I hate a lot. I think Listen, I don't even have to argue. Just
keep going on your own. You're doing a good job of arguing for
me.
Oh my god. Just finish the segment. This is why I didn't want
to come in while you're still doing this. Okay. All right, sounds
good.
Okay, every Thursday, like multiple times a a month, I would
be I I'm literally I am literally a Zionist, but I just like
I'll just engage. I'm I'm super empathetic to like I think the
the Palestinians like got really and there a lot of like downsides,
but this never happened. We'll finish the asold thing and we'll
go back. We never this this kind of stuff never happened. People
never acted this way. I don't know why. And I think, hold on,
I'll read Marty Epstein's thing. As a Jew, Hassan does not strike
me as anti-Semitic. Yes, there is an overlap, but by the way,
Judaism and criticism of Israel, but it's not prior pure hatred
of Jews. We as Jews need to be less neurotic about this. Well,
I think that's the my issue, Marty Epstein. I think the thing
is his beliefs and his oppressor oppress dynamic the like worldview
he has. I think it manifests as something that's akin to anti-semitism,
right? But it's not anti-semitism. It's it's like akin to it.
In effect, it becomes something that basically in his opinions,
in his advocacy, he would advocate for the same things anti-semites
would, but it's from a totally different basis of belief that
is it's really like narrow and really uh shortsighted to call
it anti-semitism in my opinion. But I like I think you have to
engage with like what his actual arguments are in most most cases.
Uh you have to rewind when we go back into clips. Mark my word.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Fine. like with so we can get contextified
it by saying if this is what we need to deal with to fight against
fascism then it's okay. No, you don't have to deal with this.
You don't have to have idols that are
manipulators, pests, psychotic
um you know like emotional like just like weirdos. Like you you
don't need this person does not need to be your avatar. And I
I think that Destiny was not always like this. I remember like
I would be on the Train Rex podcast with Destiny every Thursday.
Like multiple times a a month I would be talking to Destiny and
this never happened. We never this this kind of stuff never happened.
People never acted this way. I don't know why. And I think is
that really true? I thought that podcast was like Crazy Unhinged.
Wait, which podcast? He was like, "Oh, we used to be on we used
to be on um Trin's podcast together and Destiny never did this.
This never happened. Nobody ever went off off the Nobody ever
went off the rails." I'm like I'm like, "Give me a second. I
got to reconnect. My headphones go off." Oh my god. This guy
in his headphones. Holy. The scuff was uh pretty pretty edgy.
Okay. I do remember plenty of times where uh Destiny would spur
out. Um, the one that comes to mind is that um she was uh was
she like a former Twitch employee and she had that um Twitch
emote and he went off on her about uh was it I want to say periods,
but that sounds really really weird. I don't know. I My headphones
just reconnected. They were doing the clicking things. Do you
need new headphones? No, it's just if I walk away and I walked
away a little while ago, then they'll sometimes start clicking.
They get this weird clicking thing, but it it's they usually
only stay disconnected for two seconds. Sorry, I said my headphones
had to reconnect. But anyway, no, no, no. It's not it's not the
same meme. They don't die. It's just they're they like the audio
clicks like every every two seconds there's like a it's like
too much to actually stream through. I have to reconnect them.
They're reconnected now. So, I think what he what he more means
is like the level of like talking about Asmin Gold's dead mom.
That's probably the level of vitrial that he's talking about.
So, that's probably what we should like look at. Was that happening
on the train wrecks podcast? Was he going to like that extent
where he's going like crazy crazy? Oh, did me leave? Okay. No,
I'm still here. I just don't hear anything. Hello. Wait. Meow
doesn't hear me. Oh, she just didn't hear me. Oh, okay. All right.
And this never happened. That's fine. We never This kind of stuff
never happened. This person never acted this way. I don't know
why. And I think Assan is more like this now. Maybe I'm even
more like this now.
Everybody just needs to chill the out, man. What are you doing
saying this? Okay, everyone needs to chill the out. This is what
everyone talks about. Yeah, I know. I know. We can watch this
at some point. We'll see. Optimally, so I'm I'm basically against
it. Do you think that it will actively work against it just for
the you know to get down your Damn, Asen Gold's hairline went
crazy back here. He was uh post your hairline. Post your hairline.
Post your hairline. No, I'm good. Yeah, that's what I thought.
really just take a step back and think what the are you doing?
What the are you doing? It's crazy. It's je it's not you're noticing
it finally. Well, I I mean I I did So, the reason why is that
I I sent a photo to a friend of mine. You can probably guess
who the friend is of who who I sent the photo to. Uh it was this
one, right? I sent this photo to him uh the other day cuz I had
seen it and I was like, you know, we used to be a everybody used
to be able to get along and, you know, disagree and things were
fine and everything was okay. But then over time things got more
and more radical. They got more and more extreme and they got
more and more serious and it's been uh it's it's embarrassing.
You've definitely gone off a cliff since the death trial. I don't
think that I'm really as extreme and I've I just I think there's
reason to be more hyper like more vitriolic now. There's definitely
reason to be that, but it's like there's like a level of I think
Destiny had to basically gaslight his audience into believing
that like he could say anything any any weapon that I use is
justified against these people. And realistically, he got like
that argument from Josiah. What Josiah is the person who like
broadly convinced him of this. Okay. Have you ever heard Josiah
say anything near what Destiny said? Josiah is very meticulous
about how he criticizes people, right? He is like, I won't I
won't give people, you know, I won't give people charity when
they don't deserve it. When they won't give me charity back.
That's what Josiah does. No, it wasn't Dr. K. It was Josiah who
convinced him of like you can't like negotiate with conservatives.
You can't like be super uh what would what the word you can't
do uh civility politics with conservatives when they refuse to
be civil, right? But that doesn't mean that you can just like
hurl slurs at them or talk about their dead mom or talk about
them d like how you want them to die, right? Talk about how you
think they should be killed. It doesn't mean any of that. That's
That's the problem. And you should know that because Josiah's
the person who convinced him to do it and Josiah's never done
anything like that. Josiah's never come close. The dude's mother
isn't dead. Asmin Gold's mom isn't dead. What? Are you sure?
I'm almost positive she is. Wait, but it's Asmin Gold's mom that
that this guy was talking about. Tried to dial it back in because
I think there have been instances where I have been extreme.
But overall, I I try to be as fair as I can be. But even I fall
short of this. I think that's what happens all the time. similar
Salvation stuff that's fine Trump's saying appeal to Salvador
changing constitution for him. Well, there are certain things
like for example I don't I don't like this appeal to authority
of the Supreme Court when everybody can can all collectively
agree that Citizens United was a bad decision. When Citizens
United exists as a ruling of the Supreme Court and you know they
overturn Row versus Wade, I'm not going to act like the Supreme
Court is the universal arbiter for morality and justice. Okay?
I'm just not like I What? Hold on. Row versus Wade. I'm not going
to act like the Supreme Court is the universal arbiter for morality
and justice. Okay? I'm just not like I that that's again I don't
I don't get my morality from the Supreme Court. I don't get it.
That's fine if you don't get your morality from the Supreme Court,
but you should operate as if the Supreme Court has a vital role
to play in your country and you should expect the president to
respect the independence of the other of the other two branches
of government. Like like the whole thing that's the problem with
the United States, okay? Runs on handshake deals. Hey, these
three branches, they respect each other. They don't just totally
with each other all the time. They didn't overturn it, but okay.
I don't even like what they did, but it sounds but it sounds
right. Wait, I thought they overturned the president of Roie
Wade. Did they not overturn it? I thought they overturned Roie
Wade. They overturned Roie Wade. They didn't over They didn't
make abortion illegal. They overturned Roie Wade. No, that sending
it to the states is overturning Roie Wade. That's overturning
Roie Wade. Roie Wade was not saying um Roie Wade was not a law
that says abortion is legal illegal and they reversed it. Roie
Wade was saying here's like the argument for why you have a constitutional
right to an abortion and it was a bad ruling and they overturned
it. Now you don't have a constitutional federally enforceable
right to an abortion in any way. So it's just at the state level
they get to decide. Anyway, sorry that's super weird that you
said they didn't overturn it cuz they absolutely did overturn
Roby Way. Get it from the president. I don't get it from anything.
I get it from myself. And so, no, I'm not going to just automatically
attribute and say, "These people are right about everything."
So, when they make a bad decision or they do something I disagree
with, I'm going to say that. And so, that's it. The Supreme Court
is not God. No, it's not. And so, anyway, but that's that's not
my point, right? Uh, it wasn't Asmin's dead wife, Sudan. It was
Asmin Gold's dead mom. My point is that the causes that he is
trying to promote, he is actively making them worse by doing
stuff like this. And this is actually one of the less problematic
ones because a lot of people don't like me etc. It doesn't really
matter. But anyway, uh some make drugs destruction over laws
and traditions around. It's so funny that like this guy's such
a when he's like commenting on political stuff and then he just
comes through and like curb stomps destiny out of nowhere like
that to the point that I don't think Destiny could even react
to this without just going like this guy this guy will support
Trump deporting people from our country and then he thinks he
could say this. That's like the only It'll just be about Asmin
Gold's advocacy or something. It won't be engaging at all.
Anytime a black person or a female person is cast in a video
game. Yeah, this is the thing. And and again, this is another
example. Anytime a black person or a female character is cast
in a video game, meanwhile, um you know, when I played South
of Midnight recently, this is the most recent game. I was relatively
positive about it. Even with Veilgard, I said that, you know,
it wasn't as bad as people were making it out to be. Um I've
defended this stuff multiple times. And so again, just keep in
mind that when these people attack me, they use straw men of
things that I never said and lies. And when I attack them, oh,
I wouldn't I wouldn't say that. I think that's that's going pretty
far now that Destiny is doing that here. But the thing is with
Asmin Gold, you could definitely just attack the things he said.
Okay, you can 100% just attack the things he said, make predictions
based on what he said, and see his predictions unfold in the
future pretty easily. I think this is going way too far. It's
unfortunate because with other people than Asmin Gold, I think
actually straight up Asmin Gold like Asmin Gold is probably the
worst person to make these arguments cuz I think I think you
could plenty argue and condemn Asmin Gold without having to go
to any hyperbole or any hypotheticals. You just criticize the
statements. I'm referring to something that they're saying in
their own words. That's the difference is that I don't need to
lie about other people in order to get my point across. They
do. And that's sad. People doing that a lot with you. Yeah. And
so anyway, that's what I think about it. Um I don't want to hyperbole
is entertaining. It is entertaining. It's just going to also
work against your movement like really significantly, which is
fine. Get into a whole lot more drama, etc. But um again, and
I can almost guarantee you Yogi is like um he loves the circus.
He just loves the circus so much. He He just wants to be like
the uh I don't know. It's It's so crazy. Uh my favorite thing
about Yogi is that he loves the circus and he thinks he's a watcher.
He's He thinks he's in the stands, but he's actually an act in
the circus. He's like He's like a uh like a not a roadie. He's
like the like at a He's like the um the clown or whatever. The
rodeo clown. He's like the rodeo clown for the circus. even though
that's technically even though that's technically at a rodeo,
but he's like um yeah, he's like he's there. He's like doing
a bunch of work, but he's like not he's not like even getting
fame or like anything good for it. He's just kind of like risking
his like mental health and risking his well-being, but he gets
no real payoff from it. It's crazy. Is never going to actually
address what I said. He's never going to justify what he said
about, you know, those other people or whatever because he knows
that it's indefensible. He knows somewhere like he's not Destiny
is not stupid. He knows that it's indefensible. He knows he's
gone off the edge. And he might not accept this now, but he will
in the future. He's 100% going to address this. Well, no. No,
he'll address what I'm saying, but he's not going to address
the um the the context of what I'm saying, the actual uh substance
of it. He's going to create um you know, again, uh for for blasting
them for it. You're not blasting anybody for this. Like, um malicious
firing of federal employees. Yeah. What if you think that somebody
has a job that they shouldn't have? Like, is that really a bad
thing? How is it malicious? Like, I don't know. I think there's
a lot of people that work at the government that that have jobs
that are useless. Sure. True. Let's get uh let's get Yogi on
right now to come in and say that actually talking about um JD
Vance Asmin Gold's dead mom um that that's actually like really
good and helpful to the progressive movement to the to the liberal
movement in the United States. Talking about this guy's dead
mom definitely doesn't hurt the movement at all. Definitely doesn't
fire up voters on the other side. Definitely doesn't push people
away from our movement at all. I want I want Yogi to come and
make that argument. Hold on. You guys can get mad at Yog all
you want about his opinions, but at least he comes on stream
with just a asks.
That's true. That's true. Well, not right now. I don't think
he actually No. Yes, but there is a good chunk of you when he
does the Discord or ban, none of you guys go on. Okay. Yog has
balls. Uh, most people come on for Discord or ban. Yog will come
on without Discord or ban sometimes. Yeah, absolutely. And you
Jesus these false realities, right? And so anyway, um is he gonna
twist words and clip chimp for sure? Yeah. And uh anyway, so
angry now he is. And um I want to say that if Destiny is going
to come back and explain, oh, this is it's actually okay. It's
actually okay for me to act this way because there's some greater
good and it justifies all my bad actions. I I I don't want to
hear it. I don't care about it. I mean, he's not he's literally
not he's incapable of doing that because he's in too deep, right?
I I haven't heard him make an actual argument defending his conduct
in a long time that wasn't just him basically like uh doing the
exact thing he got mad at Vosch for the simulacrim thing or if
we call it webbing. They're kind of interrelated concepts, right?
Where he won't actually respond to what's being said. He will
just like sort of make up like he'll read like a chat message
and make something up. What conduct? Uh so the the conduct here
is him talking about Asma Gold or talking about JD Vance Asma
Gold's dead mom. With me, it's the the doxing and uh calls for
death. With uh with the pixie stuff, he it's like obviously the
uh the sending of non-consensual. He doesn't really ever defend
his own conduct. He just attacks other people. That's what he
that's all he can do. And he has to point his community at other
people because if they don't have somebody to attack, they will
look at him and start questioning things, right? So, he has to
consistently point them at people to attack because he cannot
answer for his own conduct in any sense.
Uh it's right. And so anyway, yeah, it's and unfortunately for
all of us, okay, this is one of those up conflicts where for
Destiny doing this, Destiny spiral downwards where he's attacking
everybody. It's super profitable for everyone else, right? Like
it's it's everybody else has incentive to like engage and and
laugh at him and point and laugh and and engage back and so he's
going to he's going to make money on the way out. Everybody's
going to make money on the way out as he like spirals down infinitely.
It's not worth taking seriously or listening to. And I think
that a lot of people have come to that same conclusion with Destiny.
And I think that's probably part of the reason why he's acting
so angry. I think that the best thing that he can do is to just
move past this and not act this way anymore. It's not helping
him. It's not helping anybody. It's certainly not helping the
causes that he hopes to produce or to promote said a million
times he's done a discussion with you. Why would I want to engage
in a conversation with a person who intentionally lies about
me multiple times? Why would I Why would I ever entertain a conversation
with a person who lies about me and makes up? Really, that's
a great point. I wonder if he has Counterpoints in his chat right
now saying just talk to him. I I talked to Counterpoints the
other day and I was like, "Yeah, it should probably strike you
as like strange that Destiny won't give you any evidence for
the claims he's making, right?" And and Counterpoints's response
was, "You should really try to talk to him about it." I'm like,
"Why the why why would I talk to the guy who's like trying to
call for my death? Why am I supposed to go talk to this guy?
That's crazy. That's nuts. That's a nutty point to make, bro.
Just go talk to him. What? He just called He's just a little
little call you. There's just a couple calls to you. That's all.
Really? Why would I do that? I I don't I don't want to get down
and and argue with people. I'm listening to what he says. If
he has something that's very important to say, I wonder how it's
affected the amount of emails he gets. It really feels like there's
DG brain drain and that's why his arguments are becoming more
rhetoric over info. Yeah, I think so. I That's what I That's
my opinion as well, Top Bronson, is that basically he stopped
getting like all of the info he was getting from everybody all
the time and a lot of people drifted away and that was why his
arguments are Yeah. just like broadly him flailing and not really
doing the like and I mean I'm guessing a lot of his emails or
a lot of the stuff he would get would be from Pisco or Josiah
like Josiah is massive as a research. Josiah used to work a full-time
job and do his channel at the same time and work for Luke Beasley
at the same time. Josiah would spend literally every free moment
he had and somehow he had a girlfriend. I think he got engaged
or something at the same time but he had like a full-time job
and he was doing his channel and building it up and he was working
for like Luke Beasley. So he would literally just write politics,
live, breathe, write politics all the time. He must have worked
like a 100 hours a week for like I don't know 18 to 24 months
and then and then he eventually he now he's just doing his channel.
He probably has a little more time to relax. But I'm saying that
like that's a level of like work ethic that I don't think Destiny
is equipped to match in any way. And by the way, I'm not either.
So I'm not necessarily even trying to throw the first stone there.
Um but that's why that's why Josiah is successful and that's
why he's like so informed all the time, right? He's putting like
60, 80, 100 hour weeks in consistently all the time. Anyway,
I've seen it. That's it. Asmin lies daily, though. Why the would
you listen to anything he says? What do you mean? Yes, Asmin
Gold's the worst politically. What do you mean? He's We're evaluating
the statements as they're made. Why do we uh We don't need to
We don't need to like look at what he's saying here on a factual.
He's literally talking about why Destiny's like unhinged. Why
Destiny looks so bad to everybody? Why is like 80% of DG European
now? I don't know. That's what's up. Yeah. Why? Why would I Why
would I do that? What's the benefit in me for doing that? Nothing.
So, what has Destiny lied about? Oh, he's going to say the lie
is making up things that Asmin Gold wouldn't do. That Asmin Gold
wouldn't be like defending anything the Trump administration
does. And that's that's the thing, right? That's what he's saying
the lie is. But Destiny does like maliciously lie about people.
Why would I engage with a person that continually lies about
me and makes up straw men that I don't even support? Really?
How could I How could I gain anything out of that? Yeah, it's
that simple. Oh, do you want to see him debate Jordan Peterson?
I I haven't seen that. I I Hangingler, what part of you believes
that? Why would you ever believe that? What part of him? Hold
on. Destiny is basically unshackled being quasi canceled when
the court case is over. He will regulate. He was he wasn't canceled
or anything when he was doing the Trump when he's talking about
that cancer kid. Was he? Maybe with the cancer kid. I can't remember
for sure. Why would you pretend that this hasn't been who he
has been for like two years? It's crazy. I That has to be Yeah,
that has to be trolling. the cancer kid who was at the State
of the Union speech. Maybe that was after he got um quote unquote
cancer. Oh, the the cancer kid was after the fact. Yeah. Yeah.
But I I I just can't believe that people are like, "Oh, he um
Oh, I can't believe Kingler just said that. That's uh that's
wild." Him talking to Jordan Peterson. I saw like 10 minutes
of it, but that was about it. Yeah. Prove him wrong. I don't
need to. I think his situation has itself. Oh god. Kingler, you're
in trouble. Yogi just agreed with me. Yo, okay just said obviously
he's not obviously he's not changing he's just been like this
that's up when his when Destiny's biggest defender is like no
no this is who he is actually that's the thing I I don't need
to time has already proven it wrong in general scared people
say can I that I'm scared as much as you want right like I think
this is the thing a lot of chatters really like the debate content
and they like the arguing content I don't like doing that I've
never liked doing that and I don't really have like a big ego
in general so it's not important for me to like prove to chatters
I don't recall what Dusty said about the cancer kid to be honest.
Stop watching his cont matter that much to me in general. So
why would
MC boot says how bad is this whole incident this life? I have
no idea dude. I have no idea. I don't care particularly. Sorry.
Like I guess that's a question you could ask. I just that's broadly
not something I'm concerned with or care about. I play into a
person who is intentionally dishonest. And I think that when
you enter into a conversation with a dishonest person, you cannot
win because they'll just lie. They'll just lie and make up things
that aren't true. They're not approaching things in good faith
at all. So why would you for any reason do that? It's that simple.
You can't argue with crazy. Yeah. Uh there's no reason to do
that at all time. It's a lost time. Yeah. It's like the inherited
uh proving yourself all the time. So exhausting. Yeah. I'm not
I don't care about that. Yeah. It's not relevant to me at all.
It's basically lost time. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. Defend this random.
Yes, he's unhinged and morally bankrupt, but Asmin Gold is being
an Essler here. He is just pearl clutching because it's beneficial.
He doesn't actually care. Um yeah, sure. You I mean you could
say that but you understand that that's just mostly informed
by you like disliking Asmin Gold, right? Like the way as nothing
Asmin Gold is saying is incorrect. He has no reason to go be
in a call with Destiny. It would not serve him whatsoever and
he just makes decisions based on what serves his interest. Now
you can call that like him being an Fsler in pro clutching. But
he just told you that he's going to do what serves his interest.
Pro clutching here serves his interest. He's making Destiny look
horrible. He totally totally ripped Destiny in this situation.
And this is very often what happens, right? This is what happened
with the um if you remember the Lwig cutie Cinderella thing
uh when Lwig like totally brutally him on Twitter. Yeah, that
was that was the same thing. Destiny just decided to start like
laughing at cutie Cinderella and I made some joke about how with
her revenge not her revenge born her um what would you call her
deep fake like we can all share a little bit of cutie Cinderella
and basically everybody was like why the would you do that and
Lwig basically just totally owned him right at least I have a
wife yeah that's like the that's the same thing did I say AI
generated about $5
I just hate when people me if only I had a better word for that
I know I'll call it simulacrim instead head. Yay, that sounds
much smarter. Uh, the similacrim refers to never ever looking
at the other person's thing. Like you're building it, right?
You could say straw man. Similacrim maybe same thing. It's referring
to the concept of like refusing to ever engage with what they
were saying. Straw man is usually like hearing their argument
and then misrepresenting it, right? This would be like you don't
even hear their argument. You just build up a totally a totally
disjoint representation. So, it's a little it's a I think it's
a little different, but yeah, you could you could say, "Oh, they're
not the same thing." Uh, Asmin is just a He knows Desi would
him. It doesn't matter. He's not He's He's literally not even
saying he's like I I just not gonna have an argument with this
person. He's or act as if you just don't know their argument.
Sure. Like you you guys can say this, but why would you ever
engage with like why why did so many DJers get mad when Desi
debated Nick Fuentes and lost to him on Fresh and Fit, by the
way, because he refused to prepare. But why why would you get
mad when Desi goes to debate Nick Fuentes? Lots of DJs get really
mad about it. It's like, well, what's the what's the point? He's
just helping like somebody who's totally unhinged, right? He's
helping he's helping platform that person. As Gold just feels
the same way that Destiny's like a super harmful, super unhinged
person that he has no interest in platforming being in a conversation
with. And I think that's like pretty reasonable. Yeah. Like this
is literally how you enforce decency in society. Hey, you're
like a like this guy's sitting on the side of the road like flinging
feces at people. I'm not going to travel down that road anymore.
I'm not going to go. It doesn't matter if that guy's Plato and
he can make the best arguments in the world. He's throwing He's
throwing his own [__] at people. I don't want to
be around him. He's gross. He's like disgusting. He's sitting
there like jerking himself off throwing his [__]
at people. I don't I don't I don't want to be around him. That's
That's who Destiny is. He's like the town drunkard who's like
throwing his at people. He's like a hobo. It doesn't matter if
he's uh whatever that philosopher hobo was in Rome or in Greece
or whatever. Doesn't matter who he is, right? He's sitting there
throwing his at people. Dioynes. Yes, he could be Dioynes. He's
not, but he could be. You're part of the group that called He
was almost done with this segment. Oh, sure. We can go on. No,
I I I'll come back. I just feel not saying anything. What is
this? Oh, I mean, you can say stuff if you want. Oh, I just I
don't want to comment on this. Asmin Gold, what's wrong with
Destiny's beard? Okay, he got rid of the I think he got rid of
this now. I think he's doing the goatee again. It's like it's
like the hand of God came down itself to make him look like a
a not that he is, but the hand of God came down and was like,
"You are acting bad. I'm going to make you look like a I've cursed
you to have a goatee." Boom. And it touched him and now he has
a goatee is to look He's cursed with looking like a It's up.
Well, it's not really up. It's actually kind of burned in every
way. So, oh my god, my biggest op is here.
I didn't say anything. You have a problem. Continue on stream.
Continue. What is this? Rile just like this. My sister a way
bigger fan than me. I'm literally only an Impact Holders fan
because of her. I used to watch She used to watch it every single
night before bed. And I used to hang out with her sometimes in
her room and we would watch it every single time. And when we
lived together, she would have it on 24/7. 24/7. That's all that
lady Wait, did the screen cap come from this? Does it literally
have your warp? Oh, it does have your warp text on it. They did
get it from your Oh, that's crazy. Watch. Can I just say how
funny it is that
that is crazy that like the queen era do this thing where once
they've decided they're going to accuse the guy or don't like
her or whatever. Okay. Yeah, it did come from this meme. That's
crazy. All right. Okay. We're done with Asmin Gold. We're done.
We're going to go back to